do you have advice for young people so
you you've had a heck of a life
uh you've done quite a lot of things
start before mit but starting with mit
is there advice here for young people in
high school and college
how to
um
have a career they can be proud of how
to have a life they can be proud of
i was asked by somebody uh
for quick advice uh
for
his young children he had he had twins
when they enter adulthood he said give
me give me your advice for them in a
letter
i'm gonna give it to them when they turn
21 or something
so
then he had i thought i was at a party
and then he handed me this sheet of
paper and i thought oh he wants me to
write it down right now so i i sat down
i started writing and i figured well
what would you want to tell someone at
age 21
you're already done so i wrote it down
then i tweeted it and it's sitting on
twitter but i tell you what i said i
said
my advice if you're entering adulthood
focus your energy
guard your time
train your mind
train your body
think for yourself
curate your friends
curate your environment
keep your promises
stay cheerful and constructive
and upgrade the world
like that was the 10.
upgrade the world that's an interesting
choice of words upgrade the world
upgrade the world
it's like an engineering energy it's a
very yeah it's a very engineering
themed
uh keep your promises too that's an
interesting one i think most people
suffer because they
they just
they don't focus
like you got to figure out i think the
big risk in this world is there's too
much of everything yeah
like you can sit and watch chess videos
100 hours a week and you'll never get
through all the chess videos
right there's there's too much of every
possible thing every too much of every
good thing so
figuring out
what you want to do and then
everything will suck up your time right
there's a hundred streaming channels to
binge watch on so you gotta guard your
time and then
train your body train your mind
and control who's around you
control
what surrounds you
so ultimately in a world where there's
too much of everything
then
you're just laser eyes it's like those
laser eyes you have to focus
on just a few of those things
yeah i mean
i got a thousand opinions we could talk
about and i could pursue a thousand
things but i don't expect to be
successful and i'm not sure that
my opinion in any of the 999 is any more
valid
than the leader of thought in that area
so
how about if i just focus upon one thing
and then uh and then uh deliver the best
i can in the one thing that's that's the
laser eye message
the rest get you distracted well how do
you achieve that do you do you find
yourself given where you are in life
having to say no a lot
or just focus comes naturally when you
just ignore everything around you so how
do you achieve that focus
i think it helps if people know what
you're focused on
so you everything about you just
radiates that people know people know
this
if they know what you're focused on then
you won't get
so many other things coming your way
if you
you know if you dolly
or if you if you flirt with 27 different
things then you're going to get
approached by people in each of the 27
communities right
you mentioned
getting a phd and
giving your roots at mit do you think
there's there's all kinds of
journeys you can take to educate
yourself do you think a phd or
school is still worth it
or is there other paths through life
that is it worth it if you get to pay
for it is it worth it to spend the time
on it
the time
and the money is a big cost i i think um
time probably the bigger one right it
seems clear to me that the world wants
more specialist
it wants it wants you to be an expert in
and to focus on in one area
and it's punishing uh generalist uh jack
of all trades but especially people that
are generalists in the physical realm
because if you're a specialist in the
digital realm you might very well you're
the person with 700 000 followers on
twitter and you show them how to tie
knots
or you know you're the banjo player you
know with 1.8 million followers and
whenever he types banjo
it's you right yeah and so
the world wants people that that do
something well and then it wants to
stamp out 18
million
copies of them
and so that argues in favor of focus now
i mean the definition of a phd is is
someone with enough of an education that
they're capable of or have made
i guess i guess to get a phd technically
you have to have have uh done a
dissertation where you made a you know a
seminal contribution to the body of
human knowledge
right and and if you haven't done that
technically you know you have a master's
degree but you're not a doctor
so
if you're interested in any of the
academic disciplines
that a phd would be granted for
then i can see that being a reasonable
pursuit
but there are many people that are
specialists
you know
you know the agitator
yeah yeah yeah
on youtube yeah yeah
he's the world's greatest chess
commentator yeah and i've watched his
career and he's got progressively better
and he's really good he's going to love
hearing this
yeah if the agile mate over here is this
i'm a big fan of the agitator
i have to cut myself off right because
otherwise you'll watch the entire paul
morphy saga for your weekend
but uh the point really is youtube is
full of experts who are specialists in
something
and they rise to the top of their
profession and
twitter is too and the internet is so i
i would advocate
that you figure out
what you're passionate about
and what you're good at
and you do focus on it
especially if if the thing that you're
doing can be automated
the the problem is
you know back to that 500 000 algebra
teacher type comment the problem is if
it is possible to be automated then over
time someone's probably going to
automate it and
and
that that squeezes you know the state
space of everybody else it's like
like after the lockdowns it used to be
there like all these local bands that
played in bars and everybody went to the
bar to see the local band
and then during the lockdown you would
have like these six super groups and
they would all get 500 000 or a million
followers and all these smaller local
bands just got
no attention
at all well the interesting thing is one
of those 500 000 algebra teachers is
likely to be part of the automation so
it's like it's an opportunity for you to
think
where's my
um
field my discipline evolving into i
talked to a bunch of librarians just
happen to be friends of librarians and
that's libraries will probably be
evolving and it's up to you as a
librarian to be one of the ones one of
the few that remain
in the rubble
if you're going to give commentary on
shakespeare plays i want you to
basically do it for every shakespeare
play like i want you to be the
shakespeare dude because once i once
just like lex you're like
i don't know what kind of
you're you're the deep thinking
podcaster right or you're you're the
you're the podcaster that goes after the
deep intellectual
conversations
and uh
once i get comfortable with you and i
like you
then i start binge watching lex yeah
but
but if you changed your format
yeah through 16 different formats so
that you could compete with 16 different
other personalities on youtube
you probably wouldn't beat any of them
right you would probably just kind of
sink into the you're you're the number
two or number three guy you're not the
number one guy in the format and i think
the
the the the algorithm
right the the twitter algorithm and the
youtube algorithms they really reward
the person that's focused
on message consistent
the world wants somebody they can trust
that's consistent and reliable
and they they kind of want to know what
they're getting into because
this is taken for granted maybe but
but
there's 10 million
people vying for every hour of your time
and so the fact that anybody gives you
any time at all
is a huge is amazing privilege right and
you should be thanking them
and and you should respect their time
it's interesting like everything you
said is very interesting but of course
from my perspective and probably from
your perspective
my actual life has nothing to do with
it's just being focused on stuff and uh
in my case it's like focus on
doing the thing i really enjoy doing
and being myself
and not caring about anything else like
i don't care about views or likes or
attention
uh and that just maintaining that focus
is the way from an individual
perspective you live that life
but yeah it does seem that there's
the world and technology is rewarding
the specialization and creating bigger
and bigger platforms for the different
specializations
you